this video is brought to you by vincero
what's up wisecrack michael here today i
want to talk about something we've all
been watching a story that explores
america's founding principles by adding
a hefty dose of hip-hop
parks and recreation
you likely think of parks and racks a
show about small town government
woodsman libertarianism or the dangers
of doing business with the saperstein
family
she's the worst but what if it's an
accidental master class in the struggles
of founding a new country
now to say parks and rec is a show about
america's founding might sound like a
stretch but remember the co-creator mike
sure is the same guy that made an entire
sitcom about philosophy
it's like who died and left aristotle in
charge of ethics
plato okay even if mike sure wasn't
reading the notebooks of thomas
jefferson
his comedic musings on life and pawnee
may help us learn more about a very
basic problem for people trying to start
a country from scratch
that is how do you stop it from
collapsing in on itself
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
political philosophy of parks and
recreation and
spoilers ahead for the show and hamilton
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
vincero
enchero watches are stylish bold and
built to last they are handcrafted and
have the same feel as a luxury watch but
at a fraction of the price
right now i'm wearing the chrono s in
black and i really love how the watch
elevates any outfit even if you're in a
t-shirt and jeans this past year vincero
has released four brand new collections
including an automatic movement watch
called the icon
a rugged explorer watch called the
outrider and a sleek race watch called
the apex which includes a limited
edition marble release that will be sold
out soon to celebrate the release of
their new collections and their six-year
anniversary vincero is holding their
biggest sale
ever you can get 30 off your entire
order by checking out the link in the
description and hey since summer is in
full swing you might as well check out
their sunglasses while you're there find
out why vincero has over 22 000
five-star reviews by getting your own
venturo accessory today
click the link in the description and
take advantage of this year's biggest
sale with 30 off your entire order
now back to the show parks and rec
follows the inner workings of pawnee
indiana's parks department headed by ron
swanson and his over eager deputy leslie
knope
leslie has an almost childlike
admiration for american style democracy
and believes that with good-natured
leaders the government has the ability
to make our world a better place
however she is surrounded by people who
are at best apathetic and at worst
downright hostile to her grand plans i
don't want this parks department to
build
any parks because i don't believe in
government leslie is thwarted at every
step as she tries to build a park where
an empty pit once stood
take on big sugar or stop people from
drinking from water fountains like
[ __ ]
yeah so the idea is to make a fountain
that he can't do that to
before he was famous for being a deft
broadway lyricist
hamilton along with james madison and
john jay wrote a series of articles
meant to sway public opinion towards the
creation of a unified nation of states
through the constitution and a strong
national government you know
the united states of america these
articles referred to as the federalist
papers were responding to existing
criticisms of the proposed union
and preempted any yet to come and while
the stakes of forming a union out of 13
individual states and throwing a pawnee
unity concert
might not be quite the same these early
debates about american government can
help us better understand what's really
going on in parks and rec
so let's start with problem one the
danger of factions
whether you're a local parks department
or the head of a national government
there's
one thing you've got to watch out for
different groups of people all with
very specific interests all yelling at
each other in a way that devolves into
chaos
no you promised you promised that's not
fair
wait is that a question of fairness it's
so i'm going back to russia hey you go
back to russia
you go back to aquarius if you're a
student of pawnee's town hall meetings
you might have noticed a theme
no matter what level-headed plan leslie
unveils there is some person or group
who feels like their rights as an
american have been trampled upon
what's next income sir you don't pay
your income tax
whether or not i pay income taxes none
of the government's business
try to make pawnee healthier and this
guy is maddie has to go out of his way
to the nearest paunch burger
now if i want to start my day off with a
triple decker pancake breakfast pizza
i gotta go to one that's 10 minutes away
and that makes me 20 minutes late to
work every day
i work at home have you ever considered
not eating that for breakfast i'll never
consider that during these meetings and
throughout the show
leslie and the parks department are met
with an onslaught of hyper-specific and
constantly annoyed citizens and interest
groups who are never
satisfied with anything there is a
disturbing lack of benches in ramsett
park
these factions in turn trample on the
rights of others like when seniors can't
learn how to not catch chlamydia because
it offends the society for family
stability foundation
if we allow this filth to be taught to
our seniors the next thing you know
it'll be in our high schools then our
kindergartens and before you know we
have babies and thong underwear
is that what you want yes that's what i
want believe it or not
it was exactly this kind of chaos that
james madison was trying to avoid by
creating a federal republic to unify the
states
sure he might not have meant bench
people but he was acutely aware of how
say one religious group could
tyrannically impose their will on others
madison in federalist number 10 defines
a faction as
a number of citizens whether amounting
to a majority or a minority of the whole
who are united and actuated by some
common impulse of passion or of interest
adverse to the rights of other citizens
or to the permanent and aggregate
interest of the community
while leslie's chipper attitude tries to
solve the problem of factions with
inclusivity
so what i hear when i'm being yelled at
is people caring loudly at me
madison argues that the solution to
factions is to either destroy their
cause or limit their effects
and while removing the causes for the
faction sounds convenient
madison points out that the only ways
you could do this would be by destroying
the liberty that lets factions exist in
the first place or more creepily
giving every citizen the same opinions
the same passions and the same interests
in other words if leslie simply
indoctrinated everyone into her binder
cult there would be no pesky jeremy jams
trying to put a punch burger on her
beloved park
i want to sell this lot to paunch burger
here's why we make money
they make money they make burgers we eat
burgers
since removing the causes of factions
isn't really an option
how does one limit their effects for
madison factions are especially bad in
smaller republics
local politics makes it easier for super
rich neighborhood weirdos like the
newports to impose their will on an
entire
area if you go bigger madison thought
the competing factions might balance
each other out a bit
but then again he didn't really foresee
the rise of the internet or
multinational corporations but that's a
video for a different day
parks and rec on the other hand has a
novel solution to a certain kind of
factionalism in the time capsule episode
in this episode a man with a creepy
twilight obsession wants to get the book
put in the town's time capsule to
impress his daughter
the town hall meetings predictably
spiral out of control as groups and
individuals with misaligned interest
all fight to have the bible weird
paintings and dead people's ashes
included in the project
we can get a little madison in here sure
since it would be a huge
overstep to try to eliminate the source
of people's feuding about whether
twilight is demonic propaganda or an
important cultural touchstone
the role of government is to develop
mechanisms for controlling the fallout
one of madison's solutions was to have a
space for the rabble to express their
grievances while making sure the system
kept their shenanigans contained
in this light we might consider the town
hall meetings as an important pressure
valve for public sentiments
what are you some kind of [ __ ] why
don't you have
hand dryers in the park bathrooms
they're so much more sanitary than paper
towels
letting the people air their grievances
might just keep the weirdos from lining
up outside city hall with muskets
and weirdly this is a huge mechanism of
the constitution's design
letting all the chaos and anger of a
democracy be expressed without giving
into the actual
unfiltered will of the people there's
two ways we can look at this on one hand
having just survived a revolutionary war
motivated by a factional dispute between
england and the colonies
the founders understood the importance
of controlling angry minorities who
would inevitably be at odds with
government rule
on the other hand they were equally
worried about the poor masses who were
larger numbers than the landowning
classes
rising up and taking power from their
buddies who own both land and people
and that's not even getting into how
afraid they were of slave revolts again
a topic for another time besides revolts
of the poors or slaves or both allied
together
madison and his fellow federalists had
another problem how do we convince the
skeptical states to join our new union
and while pawnee isn't even a state we
can see some of the same exact problems
at play in indiana
eagleton pawnee's ritzy neighbor seceded
from pawnee long ago
disgusted by the filth of the
undesirable pores of their neighborhood
that all changes however when they go
bankrupt while eagleton isn't pushing
for a compromise over slavery
thank god they are like many of the
southern states
hesitant to give up their freedoms and
rejoin the town of pawnee
built over a hot spring with a
microclimate all its own it's an example
of how hard it can be to get different
cities or states to join together for
the greater good
eagleton is richer cleaner the town hall
meetings are exquisite
look how pretty the people are why would
they ever want pawneeans to come ruining
their nice parks
eagleton is in this sense like an
anti-federal estate unlike an
eagletonian
leslie knope sees the value in pawnee
being part of something greater than
itself
even when eagleton is broke and full of
condescending [ __ ]
i live in eagleton and frankly i don't
like the idea of living in pawnee
they're a little what's the word have no
money
and believe it or not eagleton's
bankruptcy is actually a pretty great
stand-in for one specific hesitancy in
joining into a union of states
debt if you've seen hamilton you'll
remember the definitely historically
accurate rap battle between thomas
jefferson and alexander hamilton in
which they use their lyrical prowess to
debate the question of whether debts
and wealth should be shared through the
federal government or if a state being
broke was their own dumb problem to
worry about
oh if the shoe fits wear it if new
york's in debt why should virginia bear
it
uh our debts are paid i'm afraid don't
tax the south cause we got it made in
the shade
this was an important question in the
wake of the revolutionary war
as both the federal government and the
states were in massive debt to the tune
of 54 and 25 million dollars
respectively
with paper money as useless as stock and
entertainment 720
and no country wanting to loan money to
deadbeat america hamilton's big idea was
to absorb
all this debt at the federal level and
establish a national bank
for heavily indebted states this was
awesome but for states like maryland
pennsylvania north carolina and virginia
who already
paid their debts and meant getting taxed
to pay off the debt of your broke-ass
neighbors
somewhat like the debt-ridden states
eagleton's only way to survive their
crushing debt is to be absorbed into
pawnee
forming a new economic union of sorts
pawnee since they haven't
repeatedly failed to pay back their
debtors ostensibly can borrow
more money to build more parks and
schools especially after the keen fiscal
management of ben wyatt
in the case of the constitution the idea
was that say france would be less
willing to lend money to say new jersey
and more willing to trust their cash
with a larger and fiscally savvy federal
government
so here parks and rec falls on the side
of new york-based hip-hop artist
alexander hamilton who said that
a national debt if it is not excessive
will be to us a national blessing
but now that we've seen why the founding
fathers thought that faction
should be tolerated and why a union was
stronger than a collection of states
the question still remains is democracy
even a good
system do we really want the type of
government that requires
years of meetings and compromises to
turn a pit into a community park
so here we go with problem three does
democracy actually work
we all know that america is a democracy
and democracy is about we the people so
obviously our friends hamilton madison
and jay got sweet democracy neck tattoos
and for everyone mad that well actually
america is a democratic republic
zip your burger hole for a second we're
getting there
the founders were pretty skeptical about
the whole we the people part of the
government and we're downright opposed
to a world in which each citizen had a
direct say in what's going on
john adams in a defense of the
constitution of the united states
flat out worried that unbridled
democracy would lead the masses to give
up their power
immediately to some king or idols of
their own creation
he also worried like madison that the
pores would start using their power to
rob the rich blind and to be
fair that the rich when left to their
own devices would simply rob the poor
blind
it's worth noting that adams admired the
british form of government with its
balance of powers and representative
nature
parks and rec despite being oh so
optimistic about the power of one woman
to change the world
really dives into the show that is
democracy their city council are serving
for way too long with their own dumb
ingrained ways and clear conflicts of
interest
along with the bonkers ideas held by
some of pawnee's citizens but isn't all
food bad for you i've been eating
lasagna and muffins every day of my life
for 40 years and i feel terrible
it was because of all this messiness
that the founders preferred to call
their invention a democratic republic
instead of a literal democracy
for the authors of the federalist papers
commercial republics like ours
will never be disposed to waste
themselves in ruinous contentions with
each other they will be governed by
mutual interest and will cultivate a
spirit of mutual amity and concord
a republic in the eyes of the founding
fathers is a system of government which
is indirectly controlled by the people
with many barriers between individual
citizens and direct decision making at
the government level
in other words you need a principal
leslie knope or ann perkins to act on
behalf of this guy i'm not worried about
swine flu i already have the swine flu
i'm worried about the turtle flu and
rather than hoping for some shared
patriotic interest hamilton for one
thought that it was commerce not
democratic ideals that would be the true
unifying force of the union to put it
bluntly they figured that people would
get over their fights and squabbles if
it would keep their bank balance looking
pretty
this in turn would keep them faithful to
the nation keeping their accounts in the
black
while we've more than covered the town
halls we can consider this quote from
the federalist papers
are not popular assemblies frequently
subject to the impulses of rage
resentment jealousy avarice and of other
irregular and violent propensities
is it not well known that their
determinations are often governed by a
few
individuals in whom they place
confidence and are of course liable to
be tinctured by the passions and views
of those individuals
in other words there's a few jerks who
are going to push public sentiment in a
pretty bad direction
while the media during their time
amounted to rumors spread at the tavern
and printed pamphlets
we can see the danger of misguided
masses with pawnee's own gen-soaked
katie couric
joan callamezzo calamezo's talk show
pawnee today has the clout to make or
break local political careers and they
can do this all through using emotions
like rage and jealousy to rouse tv
addicted citizens in the service of the
absolute worst ideas
yeah how can you justify raising taxes
for something that'll hurt the town
i
but this of course leaves us with the
question of whether the founders were
correct in thinking that we weren't
capable of handling an actual direct
democracy and instead needed the
barriers of a republic to keep us from
ruining
things after all we've got plenty of
problems caused by special interest
groups and career politicians
it's not that parks and rec is a perfect
one-to-one stand-in for the arguments of
federalists versus anti-federalists
but it can serve as a pretty good lesson
in what these people were thinking
but what do you think wisecrack does
parks and rec show us the best that
american democracy is capable of when
well-intentioned folks work together
or does it instead lay bear the problems
and limitations inherent to a system of
government developed over 200 years
before it was possible to slide into
those dms
let us know what you think in the
comments huge thanks to our amazing
patrons for supporting the channel and
our podcast and before you go i'm going
to give one last shout out to vincero
for sponsoring this video
check out the four new collections on
the site's biggest sale of the year by
clicking the link in the description
when you use our link you can get 30
off your entire order so take advantage
of this giant sale
as always thanks for watching guys later
[Music]